[Music]
Ford has launched the eighth installment
of the Fiesta it looks a bit like its
predecessor but this latest Fiesta
generation comes with almost entirely
revamped components of redesigned body
chassis platform and engines the Fiesta
certainly comes from a good family
[Music]
they do by filty our car tester Emmanuel
Schaefer says thoughts Fiesta has been
exciting people for over four decades
more than 17 million units have been
built so far that makes the Fiesta for
Ford what the Gulf is the Volkswagen
mainly a big seller we're taking the new
103 kilowatt gas engine Fiesta for a
spin
ford claims it uses just 4.5 liters per
100 kilometers on average it's Verdean
yes the email says the Fiesta will be
available in seven different versions
he'll be testing the most luxurious of
them being acknowledged it has large
lightweight alloy wheels and matte
chrome elements on parts of its body
that needeth photos
[Music]
like around the frontal fog lamps and on
the radiator grille the est Fiesta phone
Emanuel says Ford's very first 1976
Fiesta also came though it had four
cylinders and horsepower the latest
Fiesta meanwhile only has three
cylinders but delivers a hundred and
forty horsepower or 103 kilowatts if you
like the latest Fiesta can also be had
with a 1.1 liter gas engine less
powerful versions of the one liter
EcoBoost engine or a 1.5 liter diesel
engine
there are chrome elements on the sides
lending the car a refined look side
window gets narrower towards the rear
giving it a more dynamic appearance the
rear and back lights exhibit
similarities to the Ford b-max
the trunk can hold 292 litres of luggage
flip over the back seats and you get a
total storage capacity of 1000 and 93
liters high-end materials and stellar
craftsmanship give the Fiesta a cozy
interior matte elements decorate the
interior creating a holistic aesthetic
[Music]
it boasts a no thrills instrument
cluster
the seats are leather and cost an extra
900 euros they can be individually
heated and two different temperatures
this new Ford Fiesta is the most
technologically advanced compact car
currently available in Europe 15
different assistant systems are there to
help drivers including active Park
Assist and a system that alerts you if
you're backing into oncoming cross
traffic
the Fiesta and Manuel says this eighth
generation Fiesta has barely grown in
size but has grown more refined all
incarnations of the fiestas including
the Anala have become more classy he
says with so many options on offer
everyone will find a fiesta to their
liking those eager to buy a new Fiesta
in Germany will need to shell out at
least 13,000 euros but add some extra
features and a bigger engine and you're
looking at over 28,000
whichever equipment package you want for
this latest Ford Fiesta leaves little to
be desired
[Music]
you